tony is in Tulsa Oklahoma what do you
thankful for Tony well I am thankful for
my now healthy wife and premature son ah
very cool
sounds like an eventful year how can I
help today at least well my question is
so we went through a few last year and
made it through baby sub 1 into 2 now
we're back on one after this baby and
trying to find out with all these
medical bills and stuff our budgets
really stretched so where the I guess
where do we draw the line of taking care
of the four walls and paying everybody
that is sending us a bill if it makes
sense sure well when your uh Nate when
you don't have enough money to take care
of your necessities and all of your
bills which is what you're saying then
you have to draw a line somewhere and
what we've had to teach people to do
over the years is it's a temporary thing
but and it's a painful thing but you
have to decide intentionally who you're
not going to pay because you can't pay
everybody this month now we'll get to
them but this month we can't and the
four walls means this you have to keep
up the four walls that hold your home up
which are basic necessities and if you
keep that going and the other stuff is
just bills are behind on you'll get to
them eventually you know hopefully
sooner rather than later but you cannot
choose to not buy food because you kept
current on your medical bills that's
ridiculous and so food is one of the
items that keeps your four walls
standing up now we're not going out to
eat at a five-star restaurant that's not
food that's luxury but we are buying
basic groceries cooking at home from
scratch and you know feeding our family
we're not going to not feed our family
so we can pay a debt that's ridiculous
so you take care of food you take care
of shelter which means you pay your rent
or your house payments so don't tell me
you're current on your medical bills or
your current with stupid MasterCard
you're behind on your mortgage your
mortgage is first run after food and
then lights and water you have to keep
lights on and water on basic necessities
now you don't need a three and
dollar-a-month cable bill but you do
need basic necessities basic utilities
right and you know and then
transportation basic transportation and
that means keeping gas in the car as
well keeping tires on the car as well
because you've got to go to work if you
don't go to work in any money so we have
to keep those things flowing as well so
you know the basic necessities now we
don't use that to justify luxury
purchase while we hadn't paid our bills
it's not what I'm talking about
but food shelter clothing transportation
and utilities you probably don't need
any clothes you probably get by the
clothes you got for a little while but
if there's something that falls a basic
item under the clothing heading that's
fine but do we need a more fashionable
winter coat no that's a one that's not a
need and not until you get current on
your bills and you get your medical
bills caught up that make sense to you
yeah so I mean when I guess when you get
to that point how do you go about
approaching those people that you're
like you know I really want to pay you
we just we can't right now if you want
to call them you can call them and tell
them that it probably won't make any
difference at all okay or if they call
you you can just tell them that now yeah
the thing is you know you don't have to
accept abuse from them there's no
obligation for that and so if they
decide they're going to you know try
some collections tactic which generally
means they're going to be jerks and
they're going to try to push you around
or threaten you or call you names or
something then let them talk to a dial
tone at that point but if you want to
reach out to them that's fine if you
want to just respond and go here's a
situation we had a premature child and
you know we take care of our financial
counsellor has told us to take care of
food shelter clothing transportation and
utilities first we have done that this
month and that did not leave us enough
to take you take care of you this month
we are working very hard to clear this
up we've got some things for sale I'm
taking an extra job I will get back to
you and we're going to get this cleared
up but I can't make you a promise this
month and I can't give you any money
this month because the promise would be
based on a guess and I don't have any
money and so I'm not in your money
yelling or in Pleasant unpleasantness by
you is going to change that but I'm
willing to update you and tell you
what's going on and if you want to call
in
tell them that that's fine I can tell
you you'll get sometimes you'll get a
decent response but most of the time you
want okay
so just be aware of that now how much in
medical bills out of your pocket that
your health insurance did not cover is
coming at you uh well after our
emergency fund and some generous gifts
from family and friends we have probably
about 2000 left all good hardly any
other hardly yeah what's your also Laden
percent mother well what's your
household income eighty
we always knocked out in no time dude
well we're we're actually we're still
recovering from some other we had a
stillborn a year ago uh we're still
paying off those medical bills and okay
how much in debt do you have uh probably
into the 90s and how much of that is
medical uh the top of my head probably
nine okay what's the rest of that
student loans pretty much okay tell the
student loans they're on deferral I'm
putting on hardship deferral I'm not
paying you a dime today how much do you
owe on your car's co-op to between the
two maybe sixteen it ain't good okay so
cars are a little bit of the problem but
not a ton if one of those is over twelve
you may want to look at moving that one
along but and getting you something
cheaper but that's not the problem
here's what you're facing Tony okay the
math you're giving me is not
overwhelming you got nine thousand
dollars from still born to get two
thousand from the preemie you got a
bunch of student loans that are laying
there that you just don't pay will be
for a little while you'll get to them
you got to keep your cars current you
may or may not need to move down in car
all of that is a ratio against eighty
gives me a lot of hope that within six
months your and really really good
control and on your way out of debt
you're not going to pay off ninety in
six months I don't mean that but you are
going to get rid of these two medical
bills here's what's happening though the
medical bills are both associated with
very
traumatic hurtful uh scary
heart-wrenching things right yeah and so
what happens is every time you write one
of those checks it rips your heart out
and it puts it right up there on the
kitchen table with the bills and so this
thing is emotionally overwhelming and
that doesn't make you a bad person it
makes you a good dad and a good man you
wouldn't be a human if it wasn't
emotionally overwhelming so I'm gonna
give you permission to be emotionally
overwhelmed but I want you to hear
encouragement from me that the math
you're giving me is not overwhelming so
if you can not be a psychopath I don't
want you do that but to the extent you
can move the emotions over the side and
just look at the math you're going to
see what I'm seeing that this is very
doable well the way you were talking
when you called in I thought I was going
to hear a half million dollars in
medical bills and an $80,000 income and
I hear two thousand yeah well assuming
they they color the one that's ending
whenever it's awesome it's going to be
you know it's gone
the point is this is doable a two
thousand dollar bill a nine thousand
dollar bill with an $80,000 income or
doable and even knocking out some
student some car debt
it's doable now the student loan we're
out to roll up our sleeves and punch
that thing a little bit later it's
further down the debt snowball though
which you remember from Financial Peace
University right so yeah here's the
thing you guys have had your heart
ripped out and stomped on and it just
makes it hard to fight any fight because
you're emotional gas tank has been used
on babies right yeah I mean a hundred
days in the hospital no better man and
you can't think about nothing else
you've been fighting to win this one and
you won this one and and you got one in
heaven so I mean it's just that God man
I can't breathe talking to you and it
didn't even happen to me so I get that
you guys are hurting and I want to give
you permission to hurt but you called me
about the money
so in the mix of that I also want to
give you encouragement to say
mathematically as soon as you guys can
heal a little bit and grieve a little
bit and get past the overwhelming odds
you've been facing on these things then
this thing's going to turn out
matically pretty quick and it's okay if
it doesn't for a little while you're
going to get there though this is not
going to take you out you're going to
make it does that make sense to you yeah
I appreciate that hey god bless your
brother I'm thankful you called me today
I'm honored to speak to you and as you
get through this and as you're walking
through it you call me back if you need
help
meantime feed your family keep the
lights on keep the house payment paid in
the cars payments paid and keep gassing
the cars and then you live to fight
another day
you